Фізика – це екшн!
Я дуже хочу, щоб у мене був математичний
склад розуму, але я гуманітарій.
Вітаю, друзі!
Мене звати Сергій Колебошин.
Ми з вами знов зустрілись
на уроці фізики 10 класу.
Перш ніж ми будемо з вами
говорити про тему нинішнього уроку,
давайте згадаємо – чим ми
займались на останньому уроці?
Я нагадаю, що ми почали
вивчати властивості пари.
Розмовляли з вами про
процес пароутворення.
Я нагадаю, що на минулому році ми з’ясували,
що пароутворення може бути двох видів.
Детально поговорили про
перший з них – про випаровування.
ВИПАРОВУВАННЯ
Ми ввели термін насичена пара.
Він для нас дуже важливий.
Сьогодні ми з вами будемо говорити про
другий спосіб пароутворення – про кипіння.
Тема нашого уроку «Кипіння».
Записуємо тему уроку, а я тут
напишу другий спосіб пароутворення.
Для того, щоб експертно
говорити про кипіння,
давайте згадаємо саме випаровування,
бо в випаровуванні ми вже є експертами.
В мене перше запитання до наших гостей.
Запитання, наприклад, до Ельдара.
Ельдар, будь ласка, нагадай швидкість
випаровування – від чого вона залежить?
Від якого чинника?
Я дам, скажімо так, дві підказки.
Від температури і від об’єму.
Швидкість випаровування залежить від…
Температури.
Температури. Звичайно.
Тож, швидкість випаровування
залежить від температури.
Давайте запишемо
властивості випаровування:
швидкість є функцією температури рідини.
Залежить.
Ще одне запитання.
Тепер, наприклад, до Володимира.
Володимире, будь ласка, нагадай
– випаровування відбувається
по всьому об’єму рідини
чи тільки з поверхні рідини?
З поверхні.
З поверхні рідини. Це важлива особливість
і вона нам сьогодні знадобиться.
З поверхні рідини.
Ще одне запитання, знов до Ельдара.
Ельдар, нагадай, будь ласка, випаровування
відбувається за будь-якої температури,
чи за якоїсь фіксованої?
Тобто, переформулюю питання, і
вам теж раджу на нього відповісти.
Зараз тут вода в нас в чайнику,
відбувається випаровування?
Ні!
Так.
Володимир?
Думаю відбувається.
Відбувається, зрозуміло бо я вже
поставив запитання до Володимира.
Звичайно зараз відбувається випаровування.
Просто швидкість
випаровування не така велика,
якою вона буде, наприклад,
якщо я почну нагрівати цю воду.
Але випаровування відбувається все одно і за
цієї температури, і за більшої температури.
Його швидкість залежить від температури,
як ви вірно згадали, але факт
випаровування існує і зараз.
В цьому можна переконатися,
якщо, наприклад, ви
наллєте в склянку воду,
залишите цю воду на три доби на підвіконні
і ви побачите, що за три доби
рівень води суттєво знизився,
хоча ви не підігрівали цю
воду, вона просто собі стояла.
Тобто випаровування відбувається
за будь якої температури.
Це важливі факти про випаровування.
А зараз давайте почнемо з’ясовувати,
що відбувається під час
процесу кипіння, для того, щоб, по-перше,
записати визначення, що таке кипіння,
а, по-друге, з’ясувати чому
взагалі відбувається кипіння?
В мене є супер асистент.
Це надійний чайник. Я його вмикаю.
Давайте дивитись, що відбувається.
Температура води тут зараз
дорівнює кімнатній температурі.
Ми бачимо, що ні про яке
кипіння зараз не йдеться.
Тому вже можна робити перший висновок.
Чи відбувається кипіння
за будь-якої температури,
чи нам необхідно досягти
якоїсь певної температури?
Хлопці, як ви вважаєте?
Думаю треба досягти певної температури.
Ми маємо досягти певної температури.
Ми в цьому переконаємось далі,
коли почнеться процес кипіння.
Ми за допомогою цього термометра, (я
нагадаю це термометр, а не градусник,
градусник – це у медичної сестри, а
у нас в кабінеті фізики термометр),
ми з вами переконаємось.
Давайте цей факт запишемо.
Я думаю, що ви і так знали його
з вашого повсякденного життя,
що кипіння відбувається
за певної температури.
За ПЕВНОЇ температури.
Ми її називаємо температура кипіння –
це ви теж знаєте, але давайте
я зайвий раз це запишу (Тк).
Дивиться що відбувається.
Я зараз на паузу поставлю.
Ми бачимо невеличкі такі бульбашки,
які піднімаються з дна цього чайника,
але зараз кипіння ще не почалося.
Я поставлю на паузу.
Ми бачимо, що ці бульбашки десь
вони там зникають, скажімо так.
Що відбувається? Це в нас підіймається
розчинене повітря, яке тут знаходиться.
Із зростанням температури
розчинність повітря спадає.
Саме тому розчинене повітря
підіймається, але це поки що не кипіння.
Що відбувається далі?
Ви щойно чули певний шум.
Давайте зафіксуємо цей факт.
Це особливість певна кипіння і сьогодні,
коли ми будемо розмовляти про кипіння,
ми з’ясуємо чому вода під час
або перед кипінням починає шуміти.
ШУМ
Далі ми бачимо на стінках або на
дні з’являються в нас бульбашки.
Вони підіймаються, але вони
зникають, не піднявшись до поверхні.
Дивіться, скажімо так – оцей
шум, ця от поверхня ще не кипить,
але ми бачимо, що в середині в
об’ємі вже якісь процеси почалися.
Тому можна зробити теж важливий висновок.
Чим кипіння відрізняється
від випаровування?
Це процес, який відбувається
не на поверхні рідини. А де?
По всьому об’єму. Тому –
важлива особливість кипіння,
процес відбувається
по всьому об’єму рідини.
ОБ’ЄМ РІДИНИ
Задіяний весь об’єм рідини.
Нарешті давайте ще подивимось –
чим відрізняється від випаровування?
Ми з вами писали, що швидкість
випаровування залежить від температури.
В нас (ми знаємо), що кипіння відбувається
за фіксованої певної температури.
Давайте подивимось –
коли в нас почнеться саме цей процес
кипіння, чи буде змінюватись температура?
Давайте, по-перше, згадаємо.
Чи змінюється температура
під час випаровування?
Хлопці, запитання дуже просте.
Випаровування, випаровується рідина,
змінюється температура
чи залишається сталою?
Ваша точка зору?
Температура води?
Так, температура води,
звичайно не тої, яка зараз кипить,
а просто вода і випаровується вона. Так.
Пішли на море, скупалися в морі, вийшли.
Що ви відчуваєте?
Трохи зябко, так. Випаровування
супроводжується зниженням температури.
Що таке випаровування?
Найшвидші молекули вибігли,
середня кінетична енергія
молекул, яка є в рідині стає меншою.
Звичайно, якщо вона стала меншою...
Що таке середня кінетична
енергія – це, я нагадаю,
ми виводили: середня кінетична енергія
молекул це і є фактично температура.
Між ними зв’язок дуже
простий – це константа.
Це курс обміну, можна
сказати, температури та енергії.
Константа Больцмана і 3/2.
Тобто, якщо знижується кінетична
енергія, знижується температура.
Під час випаровування температура
трохи знижується в рідини,
а під час кипіння … (ось вона закипіла).
Давайте подивимось.
От відбувається процес кипіння.
Я беру термометр і ми
його занурюємо сюди у воду.
Я спеціально використовую асистент у вигляді
лапки штативу для того, щоб не обпектися.
Нагадую! Всі експерименти я не
раджу повторювати в домашніх умовах,
бо є певні правила техніки безпеки!
Але, тим не менш, давайте
подивимось. Зараз рідина кипить.
Ви і так знаєте цей факт
з повсякденного життя,
але нам треба його зафіксувати,
бо ми як справжні експериментатори
маємо з’ясувати все ж
таки – чому, як ми бачимо
під час кипіння,
температура не змінюється,
вона як є, так і продовжує бути 100
градусів? Тож, якщо ми подивимось
на величину температури, то ми
побачимо, що температура під час кипіння
постійно лишається 100 градусів Цельсія
за тих умов, за яких у нас
зараз відбувається кипіння.
Бо ми побачимо далі, в
наступній частині уроку,
що температура кипіння може суттєво залежати
від зовнішніх факторів, зокрема тиску.
Отже, 100 градусів Цельсія.
Продовжуємо працювати.
Дякуємо нашому асистенту чайнику.
Зараз давайте будемо з’ясовувати,
як же відбувається процес кипіння.
Але, перш ніж ми це зробимо, я
раджу поставити плеєр на паузу
і записати визначення кипіння.
Тож, що таке кипіння?
Це процес пароутворення, який
відбувається по всьому об’єму рідини.
Це є офіційне визначення:
процес пароутворення, який відбувається
по всьому об’єму рідини.
Хлопці, як бачу, вже записали.
І ми починаємо з’ясовувати від
чого залежать оці фактори і взагалі –
чому відбувається процес кипіння?
Адже що таке пароутворення?
Це утворюється пара.
А ми сказали, що по всьому об’єму рідини.
Звідки ж там взятись парі?
Куди їй з’являтись?
Бо тут, коли поверхня, коли
випаровування – все зрозуміло,
молекула води вийшла в навколишнє повітря
і утворилась пара, а там куди
по всьому об’єму утворюватись?
Давайте про це поговоримо.
Отже, ми з’ясовуємо механізм
кипіння і за яких умов він відбувається.
Тож, давайте з’ясуємо – як
відбувається процес кипіння.
Для цього, як ми тільки
що з вами домовились,
нам треба з’ясувати, а куди
випаровуватись цим молекулам рідини,
(молекулам води, наприклад, або
якщо ми кажемо про іншу рідину,
то іншої рідини) в об’ємі?
Давайте уявляємо собі якусь посудину.
В неї є вода.
Будемо говорити про воду, але всі
ті висновки, які ми з вами робимо –
вони будуть стосуватись і іншої рідини,
просто ми частіше за все зіткаємось з
водою, як в цьому прикладі з чайником,
тому будемо про воду казати.
Справа в тому, що в будь-якій рідині,
воді є розчинені бульбашки повітря.
Вони невеличкі, за розміром
десь долі міліметра, не більше.
Але з точки зору
молекули води, розміри якої
біля нанометрів - це величезна
пуста поверхня, ця бульбашка повітря.
Де вони беруться? Вони беруться,
наприклад, є якісь домішки,
якщо є якийсь пил, якщо
є накип у чайнику і т.д.
Завжди є якесь розчинене повітря.
Давайте уявимо собі
якусь невелику бульбашку.
Я її, звичайно, малюю трохи збільшеною.
З чого вона складається?
З чого складається ця бульбашка?
В неї, звичайно, є повітря, як я казав.
І це повітря чинить певний тиск.
Давайте запишемо його як Р повітря.
Але молекули води, які тут знаходяться
– для них це повітря таке ж саме, як для
молекул води тут,
які можуть випаровуватись.
Ці молекули можуть
випаровуватись сюди в середину.
Тобто окрім повітря, там
ще знаходиться водяна пара.
Чи чинить ця пара тиск?
Хлопці?
Так!
Звичайно, що чинить. Якщо є
молекули, вони рухаються. Що таке тиск?
Тиск – це результат того,
що молекули ударяються в стінки.
Вони ударяються, тобто чинять якийсь тиск.
Скажіть, будь ласка, до яких пір
тут буде випаровуватись пара?
Вона буде випаровуватись постійно,
але чи буде зростати тиск постійно?
Ні!
Тому що в якийсь момент,
згадайте минулий урок,
в нас кількість молекул, які
виходять за одиницю часу сюди,
буде дорівнювати кількості молекул,
які повертаються у воду.
Тобто конденсуються.
Бо доля молекул різна, молекула
може рухатись таким чином,
що вона повернеться і конденсується.
Я нагадаю, що ця ситуація,
коли за одиницю часу
кількість молекул, які
виходять з поверхні рідини,
дорівнює кількості
молекул, які повертаються,
називається – динамічна рівновага.
Тобто рівновага між кількостями.
А пара, яка таким чином
утворилась, називається –
насичена пара.
Відбулась ситуація насичення,
тому тиск, який буде в середині
бульбашки – це тиск насиченої пари.
Це те, що чинить тиск
з середини бульбашки.
Що чинить тиск на бульбашку?
Що ззовні тисне на бульбашку?
Вода.
Вода, гідростатичний
тиск води. І найголовніше?
Повітря.
Повітря, атмосферний тиск.
Тобто є атмосферний тиск і є
гідростатичний тиск цього стовпчика води.
Але давайте згадаємо 7 клас.
Який тиск ви вважаєте більший?
Атмосферний чи гідростатичний
тиск цього стовпчика води?
Атмосферний.
Атмосферний. Набагато більший.
Атмосферний тиск буде урівнюватись
гідростатичним тиском стовпчика води,
якщо б він був глибиною 10 метрів.
10 метрів - це плюс одна атмосфера,
це добре знають дайвери.
Тому цим можна нехтувати, тиском
цього стовпчика, або цього стовпчика.
Ми будемо казати, що
ззовні тисне атмосфера,
розуміючи, що є певна
похибка на гідростатичний тиск.
Ці два тиски вони один одного
компенсують – це умова рівноваги.
І так відбувається не тільки коли
ми вмикаємо чайник, а й зараз.
Ті бульбашки повітря які є, так
само в середині є трохи повітря,
і є трохи водяної пари.
І от вони таким чином існують.
Що відбувається, коли ми
починаємо збільшувати температуру?
Тобто починаємо нагрівати.
Я тут намалюю вогник.
Що відбувається із швидкістю
випаровування і з кількістю молекул,
які випаровуються сюди всередину?
Звичайно зростають.
Це ми згадали на початку уроку.
І, звичайно, що буде відбуватися з
тиском насиченої пари тут всередині?
Зростає.
Вона теж буде збільшуватись.
Тобто, якщо температура збільшується,
в нас збільшується тиск насиченої пари.
Причому я нагадаю, друзі, що
він збільшиться дуже суттєво.
Він збільшується більш суттєво,
ніж якби це був ідеальний газ.
Нагадаю, що тиск пов’язаний з
температурою і концентрацією цим виразом:
тиск, концентрація, стала Больцмана,
тобто стала величина (вона
не змінюється) і температура.
Температура зростає, тиск зростає.
Але ще один чинник, це
було в ідеального газу тільки,
оцей чинник – концентрація.
Ми тільки що з вами
зрозуміли, що кількість молекул,
які туди виходять – вона збільшується.
Тому у нас два чинника зумовлюють те,
що тиск насиченої пари зростає
зверхлінійно. Не лінійно, а зверхлінійно.
Ми трохи згодом намалюємо залежність
тиску насиченої пари від температури.
Ми це робили на минулому
уроці, але він нам знадобиться.
Тому тиск зростає, зростає…
Що відбувається з об’ємом бульбашки,
якщо ми тиснемо сильніше? Збільшується.
Об’єм збільшується, вона
починає збільшуватись.
Чим більша температура,
тим більшою стає бульбашка.
В якийсь момент часу що може відбутися?
Давайте тепер від тиску
перейдемо до мови сил.
Які сили діють на цю бульбашку, на
бульбашку, яка знаходиться всередині води
або на будь яке тіло? Які
сили? Звичайно є сила … Тяжіння
Тяжіння, так. І вона хотіла, щоб бульбашка
лишалась там внизу, вона
сила тяжіння направлена вниз.
А яка сила виштовхує?
Яка сила не дає нам потонути,
коли ми плаваємо у воді?
Звичайно це добре відома
Архімедова сила, сила Архімеда.
Закон Архімеда і т.д.
Сила Архімеда суттєво залежить
від об’єму того тіла, яке занурено.
Якщо об’єм став більший, Архімедова
стає більшою. І що вона може зробити?
Підняти цю бульбашку, вона
починає підніматися сюди вгору.
Із зростанням температури
бульбашка підіймається вгору.
Чи сто відсотків вона вийде на поверхню?
Давайте згадаємо, що відбувалось
коли ми дивились на процес кипіння?
В нас бульбашки утворювались,
але вони не доходили до поверхні.
Чому це відбувається?
Бо ця бульбашка потрапляє
в шар води, який ще не прогрівся.
Там звичайно в нас що відбувається?
Якщо температура тут
нижча, ніж тут,
тиск насиченої пари трохи
спадає, вода входить туди.
І що робить бульбашка? Вона схлопнулась.
І коли цих бульбашок
сотні, ми чуємо що? Шум.
Шум під час кипіння.
Це називається
кавітаційний ефект, кавітація,
коли от так схлопування відбувається. Ось
причина того шуму, який ми з вами чули.
Але якщо ми будемо
продовжувати нагрівати рідину далі?
Який механізм теплопередачі
в рідинах є головним?
Нагадаю, у нас є три види теплопередачі.
Теплопровідність, вона працює,
коли мені було гаряче брати тут,
тому що воно нагрівалось
тут – це в твердих тілах.
У нас є випромінювання,
дякуємо Сонцю за життя на нашій планеті,
але в рідинах і газах основний
спосіб це що? Конвекція.
Конвекція, тобто перемішування.
Коли відбувається
перемішування – це можна побачити,
коли в нас відбувалося кипіння, як різні
шари рідини перемішувались один з одним.
То вона в нас рівномірно прогрівається
і коли ми досягаємо певної
температури, що відбувається?
Ця бульбашка виходить на
поверхню, їх багато цих бульбашок,
і ми кажемо, що рідина закипіла.
Коли ж це відбудеться?
Коли тиск всередині бульбашки,
бо повітря там буде дуже
мало за великих температур
у порівнянні з насиченою парою,
тому тиском повітря всередині
бульбашки теж можна нехтувати.
Ми розуміємо, що там повітря стільки,
що розмір бульбашки був би долі міліметру,
а вона вже стає – ми її можемо
побачити, тобто сантиметри.
Зрозуміло, що цей тиск – це, в
основному, тиск насиченої пари.
Коли тиск насиченої пари стає
більшим або рівним атмосферному тиску,
в нас вона що робить?
Те, що ми сказали – піднімається.
Тому головна умова
кипіння і це треба записати,
що кипіння починається, коли
рідина досягає температури,
за якої тиск насиченої пари
зрівнюється з атмосферним тиском.
Це дуже важливо.
Це дуже важливий висновок
і ми зараз поговоримо – чому
цей висновок дуже важливий.
Зараз просто напишемо,
що температура кипіння залежить
від зовнішнього атмосферного тиску.
Запишіть, будь ласка.
А ми з вами продовжуємо і зараз поговоримо
про особливості цієї залежності.
Давайте поговоримо – що нам
треба зробити, знаючи той факт,
що в нас кипіння буде відбуватись,
коли тиск насиченої пари буде
дорівнювати атмосферному тиску?
Що нам треба зробити, щоб
погратись з температурою кипіння?
Для цього згадаємо який
вигляд має графік залежності
тиску насиченої пари від температури.
Ми це робили на минулому уроці.
Більш детально можна
подивитися на минулому уроці.
Якщо ви це забули, ставте плеєр на паузу
і дивіться минулий урок
або відкрийте підручник.
Я не маю сумнівів, що ви дивитесь,
поручь з вами підручник та зошит.
Якщо немає, я раджу це робити, бо так
буде якість засвоєння
знань набагато вищою.
Давайте з вами будемо будувати
цю залежність - залежність
тиску насиченої пари
від температури.
Я нагадаю, що наша робоча
формула, я її знову тут напишу:
тиск - це концентрація на
сталу Больцмана на температуру.
І ми намалюємо вісь ординат –
це тиск насиченої пари, ми тільки
для неї будемо зараз працювати,
а вісь абсцис – це
температура у Кельвінах.
Можна і Цельсіях будувати, але ми
звикли, що в молекулярно-кінетичній теорії
ми працюємо за абсолютною
шкалою температур.
Нагадаю, зростає температура
– зростає концентрація молекул
водяної пари і в нас ця
залежність є зверхлінійна,
на відміну від ідеального
газу, для якого вона є лінійною.
Тобто якійсь, наприклад, температурі.
Т1 відповідає – тиск
насиченої пари, Р1 і т.д.
В нас є також атмосферний тиск.
Атмосферний тиск за
відносно маленьких температур,
наприклад, за кімнатної температури,
він більший, ніж тиск насиченої пари
за температури 20 градусів Цельсія.
Ось тиск атмосферний, позначаємо.
Коли почнеться кипіння? Коли ми
нагріваючи, тобто збільшуючи температуру,
дійдемо до цієї точки – коли тиск насиченої
пари буде дорівнювати атмосферному тиску.
Це температура кипіння.
Таким чином, у нас з’являється
два способи закип’ятити рідину.
Перший спосіб. Нагрівати і дочекатися
доки атмосферний тиск
зрівняється з тиском насиченої пари.
Другий спосіб - знижувати
атмосферний тиск таким чином,
щоб він досяг тиску насиченої пари.
Тоді у нас кипіння почнеться
за зниженої температури,
за температури меншою,
ніж звичні нам 100 градусів Цельсія.
Яким чином ми можемо
зменшувати тиск над рідиною?
Найпростіший – це взяти рюкзак, взяти
обладнання альпіністське і піти вгору.
Ми знаємо, що коли ми
підіймаємось над рівнем моря,
в нас що відбувається з атмосферним
тиском? Він знижується, звичайно.
В горах важко навіть дихати.
Ми знаємо, що, наприклад, ФІФА навіть
не рекомендує проводити футбольні матчі,
якщо стадіон розташований на висоті
більшій ніж 4000 метрів над рівнем моря.
Саме тому в Болівії досить
часто сильні команди програють,
бо болівійці звикли грати за
такої висоти, а звичайні мешканці,
наприклад, Бразилії, Франції не звикли,
там їм важче дихати і вони програють.
Тож повертаємось до кипіння.
Піднімаємось вгору.
Наприклад, на Евересті
атмосферний тиск такий,
що температура кипіння (нагадаю
- це найвища точка на земній кулі),
температура кипіння там
біля 60 градусів Цельсія.
Ви На Евересті навряд зможете
зварити картоплю чи макарони,
тому що за такої температури
не будуть відбуватися процеси
з крохмалем в цій картоплі
– такі, щоб вона зварилася.
Є і інша ситуація. Ми можемо
піднімати атмосферний тиск.
Наприклад, примусовий спосіб.
Є такий пристрій - скороварка,
якщо нагнітати туди повітря,
то, звичайно, ми будемо посувати цю лінію,
звичайно, що тиск насиченої пари
буде доганяти це за більших температур.
При цих умовах в нас
температура кипіння буде більшою.
Якщо, наприклад, в скороварці
зробити тиск над водою 15 атмосфер,
то вода буде кипіти за 200 градусів.
Зрозуміло, що набагато швидше
відбудуться процеси варіння і т.д.
Є інший спосіб досягти ситуації,
коли кипіння розпочнеться за
температури меншою ніж 100 градусів,
тобто знизити атмосферний тиск.
Зробити це примусово.
Що ми зараз будемо робити?
Наливаємо в цю колбу води, поставимо
під колокол і відкачаємо звідти повітря.
Тобто зменшимо тиск на рівень води.
Що має відбуватися, якщо всі
наші висновки є коректними?
Вода має закипіти, хоча я її не нагріваю.
Відкачувати ми будемо
за допомогою компресора.
Можна це робити за
допомогою насоса Коморського,
але щоб це відбувалось швидше, ми
будемо робити це за допомогою компресора.
Тож, що ми зараз з вами робимо?
Беремо трохи води, ви
бачите, що вона не кипить,
зрозуміло, що вона ще тепла, бо на
початку уроку ми її кип’ятили, наливаємо.
Ми бачимо з вами – пара
утворилася, це теж зрозуміло.
Той, хто уважно дивився минулий
урок і розуміє, що таке насичена пара
і пам’ятає про цю залежність,
розуміє, чому вона тут конденсується -
ми досягаємо точки роси.
Згадайте минулий урок
– що таке точка роси.
Закриваємо цей колокол
і вмикаємо компресор.
Починається процес відкачування повітря.
Давайте трохи зачекаємо, я трохи натиснув,
щоб була більш герметична в нас історія.
Я вже бачу – утворюються
бульбашки, всередині яких повітря.
І ще що головне всередині? Водяна пара,
правильно. І ми бачимо процес кипіння.
Зараз я підняти не зможу, бо воно
притиснуто. У нас тут все запотіло,
але ми бачили початок процесу
кипіння. Ось це і відбувається.
Ми бачили з вами, що відбувається
процес кипіння за температури
меншої, ніж звичні нам 100 градусів.
Тобто кипіння – це не про 100 градусів.
Кипіння – це про ситуацію, коли тиск
насиченої пари дорівнює атмосферному.
А коли це відбулося?
Скоріш за все – при 100 градусах,
бо ми живемо при атмосферному
тиску 101300 Паскалів.
Якраз тиск насиченої пари в
нас дорівнює 101300 Паскалів
при 100 градусах Цельсія або 373 Кельвіна.
Згадайте, як Кельвіни переводяться
в Цельсії, це теж вам знадобиться.
Тож друзі, які підсумки.
Ми з вами досконало розібрались
у двох механізмах пароутворення.
Перший механізм, який? На
початку уроку ми згадували.
Випаровування.
Другий механізм - кипіння.
Ми розуміємо чим вони відрізняються,
хоча насправді – це про одне і теж.
Це про те, як молекула
води або іншої рідини
виходять з рідини і виходять або
з поверхні – тут іде випаровування,
або всередину бульбашок,
розчинених в об’ємі – тоді це кипіння.
Ми з вами зрозуміли – що таке температура
кипіння і від чого вона залежить,
цей графік вам в допомогу.
Я вам раджу ще раз
попрацювати з підручником,
де ця тема докладно викладена. Пам’ятайте,
що рекомендоване домашнє завдання
ви побачите в першому
коментарі до цього відео уроку.
Я з нетерпінням чекаю
зустрічі на наступному уроці,
де ми поговоримо про супер важливе
для нашого життя поняття (термін) –
це вологість повітря і зрозуміємо
– чому, коли в Харкові +1 градус,
а в Одесі +5, то ви в
Харкові, скоріш за все,
будете себе почувати
більш комфортно, ніж в Одесі,
де є сирість, де є більша вологість.
Про це поговоримо на наступному уроці.
Я вам дякую. На все добре.
Пока.
Це такий чарівний поштовх, скажімо
так, що ми пробуємо переходити в онлайн.
Форма навчання має бути цікавою та
сучасною. Тому я вважаю це правильно.
Можливо це урізноманітнить і відчинить
двері до нового сприйняття викладання.
Бліц по фізиці. Я одразу
попереджую, я не відмінник по фізиці.
Треба поміркувати?
Ми потім це виріжемо?
100 кілометрів на годину,
це потрібен калькулятор,
20 метрів на секунду, на хвилину,
на 60. 120. А простіше немає питань?
1200, підкажіть! Сергій, ти мені підкажи.
Потрібно в кілометри перевести.
Це 1200 за хвилину, коротше –
20 метрів в секунду. Це швидше.
Кожен урок можна
знімати, викладати в сторіс,
збирати багато переглядів
і лайки. Ну, я не знаю …